in Köln wird vor ein paar Wochen auf der
zoobbrücke die erlaubte Geschwindigkeit
von 80 auf 50 Stunden Kilometer gesenkt
so will die Stadt die Verkehrssicherheit
erhöhen Blitzer sind seit vielen Jahren
auf der Brücke montiert dumm nur die
alten Dinger sind schon lange kaputt
manche seit fast 10 Jahren und niemand
hat sich drum gekümmert heute ist ja die
Technik so modern man sagt ja immer
alles ist digital alles wird
kontrolliert aber die Dinger
funktionieren nicht das ist dann sagt
für mich eine Lachnummer entweder man
macht Restriktionen die man aus so einer
Aktion ableitet oder man lässt es eben
sein dann sollte man die Dinge abbauen
wenn sie nicht funktionieren weil die
Kölner zobrücke mächtig in die Jahre
gekommen ist und um die allgemeine
Verkehrssicherheit zu erhöhen gilt hier
seit dem 1 Oktober Tempo 50 deshalb
kündigt die Stadt an die Blitze auf der
Brücke werden auf 50 Stunden K neu
eingestellt alles eine leere Drohung
denn jetzt kommt raus seit ewigen Zeiten
funktionieren die Dinger nicht die
Staren Kästen sind nur noch Attrappen
hier gibt's gar keine Sensoren mehr die
die Blitzer überhaupt auslösen könnten
und die Messanlagen ein paar Hundt Meter
weiter sind auch kaputt vor ein paar
Tagen bin ich mit 50 weil jetzt 50 ist
lang gefahren und ein dräler fuhr ganz
aufgeregt an uns vorbei mit Stinkefinger
und ist viel schneller gefahren und ich
hatte mich schon gefreut dass er jetzt
beim nächsten Blitzer dann die sein
sträffchen dafür bekommt und wurde nicht
geblitzt und dann haben mein Mann und
ich uns sehr gewundert im Kölner Rathaus
kann sich die stadtdirektorin nicht
erklären warum in ihrer Verwaltung
jahrelang niemand für funktionierende
Blitzer gesorgt hat ich kann es ja nur
vermuten wie es war weil das ja jetzt se
den letzten Jahren ist dann die eine
Anlage den nächste und die nächste
auuser Betrieb gegangen dass man sich
fest vorgenommen hatte die die ganze
Technik auf neue Füße zu stellen und
insofern hatte man das noch nicht
angegangen dass die ganzen erneuert
werden müssen viele Menschen in Köln
verstehen nicht warum die Stadt hier so
schludert und auf die Einnahmen
verzichtet wenn man ihn repariert dass
er wieder funktioniert oder eventuell
auch ein neuen hinstellt dann würde er
sich bestimmt nach kurzer Zeit wieder
refinanzieren auf der anderen Seite
haben wir vielleicht selber ein bisschen
Geld gespart weil wir auch vielleicht
das ein oder andere Mal nicht genau auf
die Geschwindigkeit geachtet haben ach
ja mobile Blitzer sind keine Lösung die
darf die Stadt Köln nicht einsetzen weil
die Bundesstraße einen autobahnähnlichen
Charakter hat schlechte Nachricht für
Raser jetzt will die Stadt die kaputten
Blitzer gegen neue
austauschen